german foreign minister analina babak
says the nato alliance is committed to
the principle of collective defense that
means an attack on one member is an
attack on all of its members baarbach
made the comments on a tour of the three
baltic states estonia latvia and
lithuania were once part of the soviet
union but are now members of the
european union and nato
russia's invasion of ukraine has thrust
them onto the front line of the west's
standoff with the kremlin like ukraine
the baltic states also share borders
with russia and its ally belarus and are
fearful of future russian aggression
bearpaw's latest stop on her tour of the
region has brought her to the estonian
capital talin
there in a press conference with her
estonian counterpart baubach said
germany has no taboos when it comes to
delivering weapons to ukraine
no to booster for us with regard to
armed vehicles and other weaponry with
they are needing that's why we are
supporting other
partners
in a circle
of exchange ringtones in german
to to see that those partners who are
delivering right now out of their stocks
that we will fill the gaps because they
can deliver soviet materials where
training is not
needed currently
for more let's bring in our political
correspondent hans bond here hunts the
german foreign minister there saying uh
there are quote no taboos for berlin
regarding weapons deliveries to ukraine
so why isn't germany delivering what the
ukrainians are asking for
yes that's the question that's being
asked here in germany also in a very
intense manner including by
members of uh
chancellor charles's own government
coalition government
the current answer is that germany
simply does not have this equipment at
the moment available to give away as it
were
the fact is that the german army
itself is in need of a large amount of
equipment there has been very little
money spent on the german army in the
last few decades because one did not see
the need for this and now that the need
is
so urgent the german army itself is
saying that the equipment that it has
available
it needs itself for spares and for its
nato commitments and so on so what the
germans are now doing and they're saying
that they have
agreed on this in two weeks of
discussions with their nato partners is
that some of the nato partners from the
east of europe who have old russian or
soviet equipment in their arsenals and
we're talking here mainly about slovenia
it appears they will be delivering tanks
and other heavy equipment to ukraine
which the ukrainians will be able to use
immediately because it's the same kind
of equipment that they have themselves
in any case and germany will assist by
providing maintenance for this
material by providing ammunition um and
by providing some training that might be
necessary and at the same time germany
will recompense those countries that are
giving away their equipment with new
german equipment but that will be a much
longer term process
so indirect military support it sounds
like
the german foreign minister also said
that germany noted that germany's
weapons stockpiles are low as you
pointed out uh that means you know if
germany had weapons that it could
deliver would still take months what
what can germany or what can ukraine
rather realistically expect from berlin
in the short-term hunts
well the short answer to that is money
um
germany is saying that it is going to
spend another 1 billion euros on
military assistance to ukraine and it
has obviously
emphasized in recent weeks that it has
already spent a lot of money uh on uh
financial and on humanitarian assistance
to ukraine so an extra billion now for
the ukrainians to be able to purchase
equipment not only in germany but
elsewhere and germany will pay for that
then
but germany will also provide things
such as ammunition for instance
but the heavy equipment that the ukraine
is looking for the tanks the artillery
the anti-aircraft systems and so on that
is something germany cannot supply at
the moment because it needs it itself
at the same time there will be a
longer-term perspective to this and this
is something that the foreign minister
has also been emphasizing while the
battle is going on she says one needs to
think also about the next few months and
even years and in that perspective
germany will be providing more modern
equipment that might require a longer
term
delivery and would require more training
on the side of the germans more modern
equipment so there is a long-term
perspective that germany will enter into
long-term commitments to ukraine
hans thank you very much our political
correspondent